And welcome to the second Royal
Television Society and institution of
Engineering and technology public
lecture.
I'm Tim Davie.
I'm sharing tonight and you know when we
conceived of this lecture series,
our aim was to hear from some of the
world's finest minds who work in the
spaces that bridge cutting edge science
and technology with human creativity and
media.
The amazing response,
and we were lucky to be there last year,
whose those of us who saw Mike Lynch in
full flow suggested we were onto
something and the excitement in the room
tonight speaks to the enduring appeal in
my mind,
a public lectures in sparking our
imagination in many ways.
And I really believe this.
We are lucky enough to be enjoying
another golden age of advancement.
The demands public engagement and debate
over 200 years.
It was a rather precocious Humphry Davy
that was wowing crowds and causing
carries traffic jams with sellout
lectures on the nature of human progress
and scientific knowledge.
Noticeably as a friend of Coleridge,
he was fascinated by the intersection of
the subjective and the technical and the
possibilities,
the endless possibilities that this
throws up.
So tonight at this wonderful
institution,
we continue that tradition with our very
special speaker,
Dennis Hassabis,
that's the best dentist,
will talk for 35 minutes or so.
Then we'll open up for q and a and I'll
be conducting will have the lights up
and were really up for a good old
discussion with you guys.
As you know,
Dennis is acknowledged as a world
leading thinker in the realm of Ai,
which in recent years has become where
the hottest topics dominating the media
and the imagination of the public.
You know my world.
We run a recent and BBC survey which was
looking at which jobs are at risk of
computerization.
We attracted two point 3 million page
views.
People viewing that and seeing how safe
they were.
Liz needs little introduction,
but I have to say his achievements,
but even the highest achievers cv db in
the shade,
chess master,
30 World Games Championship winner five
times running.
Successful poker player,
particularly impressive double first in
computer science at Cambridge.
A pioneering video games developer lead
of numerous important pieces of research
in the field of neuroscience.
Notably his landmark paper on the
similarities of how we shape memory and
how we imagine the future was a landmark
and breakthrough piece of research and
then of course founder of deep mind in
2011,
which was then sold to Google in 2014
with Dennis becoming vp engineering with
special responsibility for ai.
Deep mind has set out a goal of solving
intelligence.
A humble objective specifically dennis
just said he is involved in building
something that can expect the unexpected
gracefully.
I think that's probably a great brief
for an audience of a public lecture.
Dennis,
the floor is yours.
Well,
thanks very much tim for that very
generous introduction.
So it's a real pleasure to be here and
I'm giving this lecture and I'm going to
talk about artificial intelligence and
its impact on the future.
In fact,
it could be the relatively near term
future.
So Ai is really the science of making
machines smart and I got into ai firstly
through the medium of games and Games
started for me with chess.
As Tim said,
I started playing chess when I was very
young at the age of four and I think if
you play chess seriously from such a
young age and you're quite an
introspective kid,
which I was,
then you start thinking a lot about how
is it that your brain is coming up with
these moves,
these ideas,
um,
that allow you to play this game and win
these games.
And I started thinking a lot about this
as I got into my teenage years.
And allied with that,
um,
I,
uh,
got into computing or actually bought my
first computer,
is that x spectrum here,
48 k with some winnings from a chess
tournament.
And uh,
when I was about eight years old and I
started teaching myself how to program.
And I think very early on in the
engineers and the audience will,
I think,
resonate with this.
I sort of realized I'm on an intuitive
level that this competed a kind of
special type of machine.
You know,
most machines like cars and planes,
they allow us to extend our physical
capabilities.
You know,
cars allow us to move faster than we can
run planes allow us to fly,
um,
but I think computers do that,
but in the realm of our minds,
um,
they really extend the capabilities of
the brain and this really came clear to
me when I used to write my first
programs and did sort of basic math
calculations and other things which,
um,
it really struck me.
You could set something running
overnight and then go to sleep and then
you'd wake up the next morning and your
computer will solve some problem for you
whilst you were asleep.
So this felt like a really powerful in
some ways,
magical.
Yeah.
Say My love of computers and my love of
games obviously came together in a,
in a kind of obvious way,
uh,
in the designing of video games.
And actually this is one of the reasons
I accepted to do this lecture is I love
the idea,
as tim said,
of the confluence of bringing together
rts and the creative arts and the iet
and sort of engineering.
Um,
and that's why I got into commercial
video games.
Um,
because at the time,
this is sort of like the early and mid
nineties and computer games are really
pushing the cutting edge of engineering
and even the machines that were being
built to run these games.
So I remember the debates in the
nineties about,
you know,
Intel is bringing out their new pentium
processes and people were sort of
saying,
well,
how much more power do we need to run
our work processes and spreadsheets and
um,
you know,
haven't we got all the computing power
we need?
And actually one of the answers was
that,
um,
if we wanted more and more realistic and
complex games,
then we would require more and more
powerful computers with larger memory
and things like graphics chips.
So for a long while games were actually
driving the development of a cutting
edge hardware.
And furthermore,
the games that I used to sort of design
and program all involved ai as a core
gameplay mechanic.
So probably my best known game was
called theme park and uh,
which is some screenshots of it has came
out in 94 and was very successful.
And it was actually the first game of
its type.
So the idea here was that,
um,
you designed your own Disney world and
thousands of little people would come in
to your Disney world and kind of play on
your rides and how enjoyable they
thought your theme park was,
would,
um,
sort of have an impact on their emotions
and how happy they were.
And then that fed into them and
economics model about how much you could
charge them for the hamburgers and the
balloons.
So the better design your,
um,
thing park was,
the more money it made,
and then that allows you,
of course,
to expand the theme park further.
So,
um,
this game and actually another game
called Sim city with the first sort of
games that had ai as a core game play
component and really spawned a whole
genre of management simulation games as
they're called.
And one of the reasons these gains are
so popular is that the ai adapted to the
way the player played the game.
So that means that every single person
who played this game had a unique
experience.
And,
uh,
people used to send in our member into
magazines,
gay magazines and write into us,
I'm showing what's the end state they
got their theme park into.
And there was all these amazing designs
that people are created that we had no
idea could be done even as the inventors
of this game.
Um,
so that really struck a chord with me
when I was around 16,
17 years old when I wrote this game.
And I'm thinking about,
you know,
maybe if I devoted my career to ai
advancing ai,
um,
what an incredible technology that could
be.
So then after having a career and
getting games and running my own games
companies and things,
um,
I then went back to academia to do a phd
in neuroscience,
which I felt was another piece of the
puzzle that I needed before launching an
effort.
Like deep mind.
I wanted to understand a bit more about
how the brain,
um,
solved a tough problems like imagination
and memory.
And I specifically pick those topics to
do my phd on because those are things
that at least back into mid two
thousands where were we will not very
good at doing in computer algorithms.
So I wanted to look at the way the brain
sold.
Somebody is very,
very tough problems that we didn't know
yet how to imbue our machines with.
And I'll come back to that towards the
second half of my talk.
So all of these different experiences
then culminated in finally in setting up
deep mind,
uh,
in 2010 and really,
um,
it's been a 20 year plus journey for me
to get to this point,
uh,
and have enough of what I thought were
the basic ingredients both on an
algorithmic level but also in terms of
the founding scientific team and making
those contacts to actually put together
something like the mind and,
um,
and plausibly go after those big
emission as solving intelligence.
So another way we look at,
um,
uh,
the company is as an Apollo program for
ai as sort of moonshot project that
really focuses on the very ambitious
longterm goals.
And we've collected together a 100 more
than $100,
knew 150 now of the world's top research
scientists in this area.
So I think the mind is by far now the
biggest collection of machine learning
experts anywhere in the world.
And another thing we're experimenting
with,
of course,
apart from trying to build ai is
actually a new ways to organize
scientific endeavor.
So what we've tried to do with deep mind
is really combined the best form,
um,
silicon valley startups together with,
uh,
the best parts of that you find in the,
in the best academic institutes like
Mit,
ucl,
Cambridge,
and so on,
and see if we can infuse that into a new
hybrid way of doing science,
which is more productive and extremely
efficient,
but still allows for extreme creativity.
So our mission then,
as Tim said,
we articulate it in a kind of to step
way.
So firstly we talk about solving
intelligence.
Um,
and we use the word solve,
which is a kind of ambiguous word there
because actually what we mean,
what we're interested in is,
is understanding natural intelligence.
So the human mind.
But also recreating that on intelligence
artificially.
And then step two,
we want to use that technology to help
us solve everything else.
Now,
um,
you know,
that might seem a little bit far
fetched,
possibly a little bit fanciful to some
of you,
um,
but we really believe actually that step
to naturally follows on from step one.
If you can solve intelligence,
and I hope by the end of this talk,
uh,
you know,
you'll,
you'll agree with this conjecture.
So more prosaically,
how are we going to solve intelligence?
Well,
what we're trying to do at deep mind is
to construct the world's first general
purpose learning machine.
And the key aspects of this are the word
general and learning.
So we're at deep mind,
we're only interested in algorithms that
learn for themselves,
so they learn automatically from raw
experience or war data,
so they're not preprogrammed in any way.
So what we're talking about here is
autonomous learning system.
The second thing is this idea of
generality.
So,
um,
what we're interested in is the same
system.
I'm actually being able to operate
across a wide range of tasks and
environments out of the box with no
reconfiguration,
so of course we have an example of such
a general learning system.
It's the human mind where we're able to
apply our minds to almost endless number
of different tasks.
Now I should say most of ai today,
although it's a huge buzzword right now
and is very fashionable,
most of it,
ai is not of this type of technology,
so we call most ai actually internally
at deep mind narrow ai and what we mean
by that is preprogrammed ai that has
been built for in a bespoke way for one
specific task and actually most of the
Ai we interact with everyday from Siri
on your phone to self driving cars is
actually a of this preprogram type of Ai
and what we're interested in is what we
call artificial general intelligence.
This idea of a general learning system
and perhaps still the most famous and
clearest example I can give her.
This is the famous deepblue match
against Garry Kasparov.
Of course,
this was a watershed moment in ai when
in the late nineties,
IBM's deep blue beat Kasparov in a six
game chest match.
Um,
but the interesting thing is I came away
from that match,
actually more impressed by Garry
Kasparov mind than the deep blue machine
because,
um,
you know,
of course it was an impressive
engineering feat,
but deep blue was programmed by an
amazing team of programmers along with a
bunch of chess grandmasters trying to
distill chest knowledge into an
algorithmic sort of construct.
And those programmers were directly
programming in the sort of ideas and
solutions into the machine.
And of course,
what that meant is that deep blue,
although it was very good at chess,
it was no use for absolutely anything
else,
including strictly simpler things like,
for example,
playing noughts and crosses which any
chess grandmaster you could trivially
teach them how to play noughts and
crosses.
But obviously deep blue,
nothing that deep blue,
new or in its code would help it with,
um,
even something strictly simple like
that,
let alone,
um,
uh,
other kinds of domains like speaking
languages or driving cause all these
other things that of course Gary
Kasparov could do effortlessly.
So instead of that,
we think about intelligence in the
framework of what's called reinforcement
learning.
So I'm just going to illustrate what the
main basic parts of that in this little
cartoon diagram because it's important
for what I'm going to show next in terms
of the videos of the,
of the,
of the algorithms working.
So you start off with your agent system.
I'm represented by this little humanoid
character and that agent finds itself in
an environment which could be virtual or
real world.
If it's real world,
the agent probably be a robot.
If it's virtual,
the agent will be an Avatar and the
agent has some kind of goal that has
been given to,
that is trying to achieve in that
environment.
And the agent only interacts with the
environment in two ways.
One is that it gets observations through
it.
Sensory operators,
observations about the world and we
mostly use vision at the moment,
but we're also looking to use other
sensory modalities soon.
And those observations are always
incomplete and noisy.
So you never get full information about
the world,
unlike say a game of chess where it's a
perfect state information.
You see everything that's in the game
world,
uh,
in,
in the real world.
Of course,
you don't get to see all the information
and that one of the jobs of the agent
system is to build a,
as accurate a model as possible of the
environment out there based solely on
these noisy,
incomplete observations.
And the agent is doing this in real
time.
These,
these observations are coming in every
time step and it's,
and the agent is continually updating
its model of the world based on this new
evidence that it gets.
And the second job of the agent is to
then pick a what action it should take,
what's the best action it can take in
that particular moment in time that will
guess best,
get it towards its goal,
um,
from the current situation that it finds
itself in.
And once it's decided what the actions
should be,
an outpost that action action gets
executed,
and that then may drive a change in the
environment,
which will then drive a new observation.
And this goes round in a,
um,
endless sort of cycle.
Now this diagram is a very simple to
sort of explain,
actually hides an incredible amount of
complexity.
So we know that if you could solve all
the problems behind the,
um,
the underlie this diagram,
this representation,
then that will be enough for true
artificial intelligence.
And we know that because this is the way
that biological systems learn,
um,
including humans and most mammals.
Um,
and in fact in humans is the dopamine
system that implements a form of
reinforcement learning.
So we go,
we went onto,
um,
test these kinds of systems,
and actually we chose to test the
intelligence of our systems.
I'm on computer games now,
a true thinking machine,
uh,
we believe would have to be embedded in
a sensory motor data stream.
Um,
you can't have true intelligence and
true thinking unless you have the
ability to affect the world that you're
in.
And the ability to sense that world.
And uh,
and so usually the,
so this is called embodied cognition and
um,
usually when people subscribe to this
view of Ai,
they normally start working on robots,
will robots.
I'm based in obviously in real world
environments,
but robots are very tricky to use.
They're very expensive.
They're very slow and they break down.
So if you talk to anyone who's who's
used or to try to develop robots,
your,
your hair,
a lot of the work actually goes into
fixing the mechanics of the robot,
the motors and the sensors and so on.
And actually we didn't want to be
distracted by that.
We wanted to focus on the intelligence
algorithms themselves.
So what we decided to use was video
games in the first instance.
And of course it's a little bit to do
with my background where it came in
useful here in video games,
um,
and use it.
And we purpose the games as a platform
for testing the intelligence and the
capabilities of our Ai Algorithms.
Now Games are really good because
obviously you can run them in the cloud,
you can run them much faster than real
time,
you can run millions of experiments in
parallel,
um,
and it's very easy to measure progress
because most games fortunately have game
scores,
so you can see very conveniently if your
algorithmic tweaks are gaining you an
advantage and whether you're heading in
the right direction based on the
performance in those environments.
And that's something that's very
important,
especially for a very long time mission
like we have,
um,
and very ambitious mission is to be able
to break down a,
an ambitious mission into smaller chunks
that are very easy to measure the
progress on.
The other key thing about games is that
obviously they were designed by other
people and other other engineering teams
and they weren't designed specifically
for ai testing.
And uh,
so what that means is that you have to
deal with all kinds of interesting
problems that you would never have dealt
with a designed yourself as an ai
designer.
Um,
and I think that's actually makes sure
that there isn't any bias in the types
of problems that you apply your ai to.
So one of the big problems of in ai
research that has been over the last few
decades is that generally speaking,
is the ai designers that also designed
the problems are and subconsciously
whether you like it or not,
you end up designing problems that you
know,
your air go isms are well suited to.
So what we started off with was actually
Atari Games from the eighties,
which were really the first iconic
platform that had a lot of very popular
challenging games on it and we decided
to start with that.
And what we did is we started with an
open source emulator for Atari Games and
we,
um,
uh,
a souped it up and made it more robust
and made it run faster.
And then we plugged it in our ai
algorithms into the system.
Now I'm going to show you a couple of
videos of the AI system working and
then.
But before I do that,
I always wanted to explain to you what
it is you're going to see.
So the AI system here,
I'm only gets the raw pixels as inputs,
so it's almost as if we'd set up a video
camera,
a observing the screen,
and I'm,
the only information that he gets is the
raw pixels so it doesn't know anything
about,
uh,
what it's controlling.
It doesn't know what the of the game is.
Um,
it doesn't know how to get points and
all it's been told is that it needs to,
it's goal is to maximize the score and
everything else is learned from scratch.
And then there's a sort of generality
component comes in again where we
require a single system to play all the
different games out of the box.
And there's obviously dozens and dozens
of very different Atari Games.
Okay.
So the first thing you're going to show
you is space invaders,
probably the most iconic game that
they're,
you know,
there's ever been.
And I'm going to show you sort of two
parts of this video.
Um,
so in the beginning,
as I roll the video now you know,
you'll see what the agent looks like
when it first encounters this
environment.
Now,
as controlling the rocket at the bottom
of this screen,
obviously it's trying actions randomly
because it has no idea what it's
supposed to be doing and it loses its
three lives almost immediately.
Now,
if you leave the machine training
overnight and you come back the next
day,
um,
the,
the machine now is superhuman at,
at the,
at the game.
So every single shot it,
it,
fires hit something,
it can't be killed anymore.
Um,
it's,
it's worked out that the pink mothership
of the top of the screen is worth a lot
of points that does these amazing
accurate shots.
And you can see that the model is built
of the world is,
is extremely accurate.
So those you play space invaders back in
the eighties wall,
remember that the,
the,
as there's less of them,
they get faster.
If you just watched the last shot,
you'll see that they sort of predicted
where,
um,
where that is going to wear that term.
Space invaders going to end up and far
as the shortest shots ahead of time.
So I'm going to show you a second video
now,
which is the game of breakout.
It's my favorite video where they show a
few more gradations of the agent getting
better and more capable.
Um,
so in this game,
the agent is controlling the,
the,
the pink bat and ball.
And the aim of the game is to break
through this rainbow colored brick wall,
brick by brick.
So to start off with,
after 100 games,
um,
the,
the AI system has,
you know,
it's not very good.
You can see it's missing the ball most
of the time,
but you can see maybe you can convince
yourself.
It's starting to get the hang of the
idea that it should be moving the bat
towards the ball.
Now,
after 300 games,
you can see that the,
the system has now got pretty much as
good as any human complainants and
almost always gets the ball back even
when it's coming back at very vertical
angles.
So we thought that was pretty cool,
but we thought,
well,
what would happen if we left the agent
running for longer and playdoh another
200 games?
And then this unexpected thing happened,
it discovered the optimal strategy was
to dig a tunnel around the site and send
the ball around the back of the wall.
And um,
you know,
it's doing that again with sort of super
human accuracy in terms of the motor
control then and strategy.
I wonder,
the funny things is,
is that although the researchers on that
are amazing,
programmers and engineers,
they're not so good at playing Atari
Games so they didn't actually know about
that strategy.
So it's,
I think,
you know,
an example of a system that you've
created actually teaching you something
which is quite an a watershed moment for
us.
So efficient in that work.
Uh,
we,
this was then fully published in nature
and the front cover earlier this year
and we actually even released the code
as well.
So you can,
you can have a look at that and play
with that yourselves.
Um,
so now we're moving onto three d games,
go a robot simulators and of course we
are interested in robots,
but as a developed as a sort of
application rather than as a development
platform.
Now I'll just show you one thing on the,
a three d stuff,
um,
so we'll have a lot more announcements,
new announcements to make her in the
next year.
Um,
but we,
we,
I'll show this sort of run this little
video of,
um,
the same agent that you saw playing the
Atari Games actually now driving a
racing car around the track in a three d
game.
So,
um,
again,
the only inputs here are the pixels,
the raw pixels and the steering wheel
controls and um,
it's learned just from your experience
driving the car around how to drive,
um,
and even do things like it's overtaking
the other cars that sort of 200
kilometers an hour.
Um,
and again,
just from the raw pixel data.
So we're now moving towards much more
advanced three d environments where
we're looking at May's problems,
uh,
and,
all kinds of,
a much more complex,
uh,
a path finding problems.
Now,
I spoke about neuroscience at the
beginning of the talk and just want to
come back and touch on that now.
So we talk a lot about,
um,
the Ai that we build it.
The mind has been neuroscience inspired
and in fact,
many of the other research areas that
we're looking at now,
we're looking to neuroscience very
closely for inspiration about,
um,
uh,
for new types of algorithms,
as to how the brain works.
So we're looking at memory,
attention,
concepts,
planning a navigation and imagination.
Now because this is a,
you know,
each one of those areas we'd probably
need a whole talk to,
to sort of get into.
So I'm just going to focus on
imagination because I think that's most
relevant for the audience here.
Um,
and it's also what I did for my phd.
Now it turns out the imagination is
quite dependent on an area of the brain
called the hippocampus,
which is actually here,
this area and pink hair at the center of
your brain in this,
um,
in this diagram of,
of the human brain.
Now the hippocampus,
it's very important,
right?
It's quite a small part of the brain,
a small brain region,
but it's very critical problem brain
region and it's been known for,
you know,
more than 50 years now that if you
damage the hippocampus,
um,
then you um,
how you become amnesic.
So it's well known that the hippocampus
is vital for episodic memory.
But what wasn't known was,
what else was the hippocampus useful
for?
Um,
for example,
was it involved with imagination now?
I suspected that it might be because
when I started reading the literature on
memory and hippocampus when I started my
phd,
I sort of came across this literature
that was talking about memory as being a
reconstructive process rather than like
something like a video tape.
So,
uh,
and that's actually the way that memory
works when you,
if you remember this lecture tomorrow,
it won't,
it's not kind of like a store,
like a video tape somewhere in your
mind.
Actually,
you will be combining it from all sorts
of components of things and experiences
that you've had before.
Other lectures,
perhaps other visits to the British
Museum as well as specific pieces of
content that are to do with this evening
specifically,
and what your brain does in the
hippocampus is always is reconstructing
that,
pulling all those parts together into a
coherent whole,
which then is recognized by the rest of
your brain as a actually an episodic
memory.
So I was thinking,
well,
if memory works as a reconstructive
process,
then if we think about imagination as
being a similar process,
but in this case is a constructive
process.
If we think of memory as trying to put
your components that you have together
in a way that your brain thinks looks
and judges as familiar,
perhaps creativity's,
that is the converse of that.
You're still bringing together those
components,
but now you're trying to create
something novel that actually your brain
judges as unfamiliar.
Um,
so I was thinking,
well,
if memory is heavily depend on the
hippocampus,
then maybe imagination is also a very
heavily dependent on the same brain
structure and the same processes.
So the way we decided to test this was
actually by getting,
um,
uh,
going around the country to interview
patients who had damage to the
hippocampus,
but only the hippocampus and there's
very rare sorts of diseases that cause
that although things like Alzheimer's
actually do attack the hippocampus,
but also other brain structures,
but what we needed were patients that
had only specific damage only to this
one brain region and we tested those
patients on their imaginative abilities
rather than their episodic memory.
And what we did is gave them fairly a
kind of simple,
imaginative task.
We would give them a word cues like the
following.
Imagine you're lying on a white sandy
beach in a beautiful tropical bay.
Describe in as much detail as you can,
what you can see and hear and experience
around you.
And what happened was,
is when we compared and broke down their
descriptions,
we scored it a in a very complex scoring
system to break that how rich that
description was.
And we compared it to age and educated
an ICU matched control subjects.
So they were actually in every way,
except obviously they had intact and
healthy hipaa campuses.
We found that,
um,
on our richness measure experiential
index measure that the imagine scenes
that be hippocampal patients with
describing what hugely impoverished
compared to the healthy controls.
And you can see that in these two.
Then if you can see this laser pointer
in these two bar charts.
So on the left hand side here is the
patients,
the five patients,
and then here are the 10 match controls
to these patients.
And you can see this is the sort of
richness index,
if you like,
of the described seeing and you can see
that the patients are massively
deficient compared to the,
um,
to compare to the controls.
So,
um,
so it seems indeed that the hippocampus
is very important for imagining the
future.
And,
uh,
actually the new scientists reported on
this,
uh,
work,
and it became quite a big study.
Um,
that was also listed in sciences or as
one of the big breakthroughs with 2007.
And the new sites has had quite a nice
headline talking about Hipaa camp or
patients being stuck in the present.
So the idea was,
you know,
they know they can't remember the past
very well and now it turns out they
can't imagine the future either.
So,
um,
but yeah,
if you were to talk to them,
they seem,
you know,
for a few minutes they would seem
completely normal to you and you'd be
able to converse with them completely
normally because they're processing the
present.
I'm in the same way that a healthy
person.
What.
So we then follow this up in Mri and we
found out of course the hippocampus
doesn't support imagination on it's own.
It's part of a,
it's a critical ct solar core part of a
much larger brain network that includes
all sorts of other brain regions from
the been or to the medial frontal Cortex
to the medial temporal lobe,
lateral temporal cortex and parietal
cortex.
So all these regions reliably come on
when you scan somebody in a brain
scanner and you'd get them to imagine
scenes.
Um,
and,
and the,
this network is the imagination network,
if you like.
So they're much more recently I was
thinking,
well,
okay,
so,
so this is how humans imagine.
Um,
but um,
what about animals?
Can they imagine as well,
for example,
kind of rat imagine.
Um,
uh,
we,
you know,
again,
we know that rats have memory,
very good memory in fact.
Um,
but can they do things like imagine the
future?
Yeah.
So before I show you the study that we
did to investigate that,
I just need to take you through a couple
of things about that we know about rats,
um,
and we know that rats can do.
So the first thing to tell you about his
place sells.
Now I'm play cells are you can really
think of them as the GPS coordinates in
a rat's brain about where they are.
So if we imagine a box that a rat might
be in a box.
So here we're looking top down on this
environment,
then the rat might be roaming around
this box.
And uh,
you know,
in these experiments you record directly
from the rat's brain while they're
roaming around.
And what you find is,
is,
um,
cells in the hippocampus fire,
I'm in specific places in the
environment.
So for example,
a cell,
a might fire only it when the rat is
traversing through this particular part
of the box environment.
Conversely,
selby be my only fire in another part of
the environment.
Now,
the,
the amazing person who discovered this,
John O'keefe,
who discovered these place cells in the
seventies just around the corner at Ucl,
won the Nobel prize for this last year.
Um,
and I was lucky enough to have him as
my,
uh,
on my vibe of committee for my phd.
So I got to know him well and um,
the entire rap literature very well.
And what I started thinking about is
since that discovery,
a place cells,
people have found that actually,
um,
sequences of place,
cells fire in,
in,
in kind of sequence when a wrap moves
through an environment.
So for example,
let's take a new environment here,
a linear track.
So this is like a linear box and the
rats moving from,
um,
from left to right here.
And what you find,
if you record from the brains of these
rats,
is that place cells will fire in order
a,
b,
c,
and d,
depending mimicking the way,
um,
and matching the way that the rat is
moving through that environment.
And in the nineties,
other people's found that when they
recorded from the brains of these rats,
while they were asleep,
after they had walked around and
navigate it in one of these amazing like
environments that the rats would replay
the trajectories they'd experienced in
their wake session before.
So you could,
you could really think about this as
rats dreaming,
so they would replay this trajectory of
Abcd,
but now this would be just,
um,
they will be sleeping soundly and it'll
be just their,
their brains replaying this.
And what's interesting is that the
brain,
so these rats actually replay these
trajectories,
an order of magnitude faster than they
actually experienced it in real life.
So if you think about dreaming as maybe
helping the rats learn about the
environment that they're in,
then they actually,
I'm learning from this much more
efficiently than they can experience it
when they are awake.
So that's,
uh,
shows that rats have memory and perhaps
they dream,
but it's not showing that they actually
imagine new experiences that they
haven't experienced while they're awake.
So we wanted to show that unequivocally
and recently we published a study with
some colleagues of mine at Ucl in ie
life that I think a unequivocally shows
that rats do imagine.
So we designed this simple but,
um,
I think quite elegant design to test
this hypothesis out.
So what we had here is a teammate is
this time.
So again,
we're looking top down on the,
on the environment,
and the team is,
has a barrier.
So,
um,
and this barrier here stops the rat.
The rat starts off in the stem of the
teammates,
um,
and it stops the rat moving to the arms
of the teammates,
but it's safe.
Lou the barrier so the rat can see past
to the arms and see what's on the arms.
So the rise initially in the first
session running up and down the stem of
the t mates.
And what we do to make the rat really
interested in the arms is we put some
food,
uh,
rice pellet on one of the arms here,
depicted by this yellow dot and on the
right hand arm and the rack can see this
when it gets to the barrier,
but it can't reach the rice pellet.
So obviously he's very motivated to
think about a to try and get the rice
pellet,
but it can't get past the barrier.
So then after it's experienced that
environment for a while,
we let the rat go to sleep and that
will,
of course,
we recording from the rat's brain while
this is going on.
Um,
and then we wake up again and now we put
it back in the environment.
But this time,
um,
we remove that barrier.
So now it's free to run around the whole
teammates.
So it does that happily,
it moves around,
uh,
the,
the stem and the arms,
both the left arm and the right arm,
uh,
and it fully explored this whole
environment.
So obviously as I've just told you with
the place cells,
what we can do is we find that there are
play cells,
let's say so a and sell DDI.
That fire,
I'm on the arm section of the maze.
Now what we can do is then go back to
look at the data we collected when the
rat was asleep and see if the rack was
imagining about those trajectories
towards the rice pellet before it ever
had experienced it in reality.
So they forget when it was sleeping in
the rat had never experienced walking on
this or a that.
Only seen that all.
And what happens is we find our
conjectures,
we're sort of proven that actually you
get,
we find if we go back and analyze the
sleep data,
you get this replay or pre play if you
like,
of this trajectory,
abcd.
And what's more is this is not just
random pre play.
You actually get more significantly more
prepared to the right hand arm then to
the left handle,
which is exactly what you would expect
if it's behaviorally consequential.
Right?
So you can.
I mean,
of course this is anthropomorphizing the
rat,
but you could imagine the rats really
wanting to get to that rice pellet and
is imagining plans of how could it get
there,
right?
Almost imagining yourself walking to the
writer Paler and then eating it.
And so,
and then it just dreaming about imagine
experiences.
Right?
So,
um,
so,
and that's really what's going on here.
I think,
uh,
and of course we're now going to look
into this further and we have a number
of plans to look at a follow on studies
from this,
um,
with more complex environments.
So,
you know,
humans imagine rats.
Imagine.
So what about,
um,
uh,
machines.
So this is something that's key
imagination to planning for the future,
making plans,
good plans about the future.
So this is obviously something that we
also want our machines to be able to do.
So,
um,
you know,
I've been titled this slide do,
do androids dream of electric sheep,
which is of course is a reference to
Philip K,
Dick [inaudible] famous book and one of
my favorite,
one of my favorite films,
blade runner.
And um,
and this is really,
I'm just going to give you a very short
excerpt here with this video of which is
a little bit of an insight into the mind
of the machine that you saw earlier
playing space invaders.
So I told you that one of the purposes
of the agent system is to build a model
of the world so they can predict the
future of what's going to happen in that
game world.
And here,
what I'm going to show in this sort of
ten second video is the machine getting
an initial input from space invaders
like this.
This is the game position and then
freely imagining or dreaming about what
might happen over the next 10 seconds.
So you can see it's,
it's dream out moving.
It's,
it's,
uh,
the rocket and it's dreaming about
getting points and shooting some of the
space invaders.
Now it's quite fuzzy because there's
uncertainty about what might happen in
the world.
It's all probabilistic.
So,
um,
it's not as certain as seeing an actual
screen.
Um,
but it's the beginnings,
I think of imagination based planning.
Now I'm just going to end by talking a
little bit about,
so that's imagination.
So once you start thinking,
well,
could machines have imagination?
What about creativity?
I just something I get asked about all
the time and of course is very relevant
to a lot of the work that people in this
room do.
And um,
you know,
I think we're a long way away from
machines being truly creative,
but I don't think it's impossible and I
think that um,
when we start to understand what this
process is,
this mysterious process of creativity
is,
um,
I think it will become actually more
obvious how to implement that in an
algorithm.
So I just want to show a couple of
little hints of things that might
surprise you.
Um,
so let's just take a picture of the
British Museum,
the front of this building and uh,
if we then say to the machine,
and this is a new type of algorithm that
was actually first a very recently
invented at Max Planck Institute in
Germany.
And then we've implemented our own
version of this internally.
And what you can do is you can give it a
autistic picture like this van Gough
picture and say you wanted to,
you want the,
that photo redrawn in the style of Van
Gough Rights and um,
and actually so you ends up with outputs
that I like this where you can actually,
it's not ready yet to be hung at the
Louvre,
but you can sort of start thinking it's
pretty surprising when I saw these
things like how a actually coherent the
output can be.
And then,
you know,
we can look at other examples.
So actually this is a concept piece of
concept art for um,
uh,
a new google that's been built in,
in Silicon Valley and we give it a syrup
painting and then we ask it's output in
is one of my favorite ones.
And you know,
producers,
pretty good version of the,
um,
of the original,
but in,
in the start of syrup.
And this isn't true creativity,
right in,
in some senses is a politic because what
we're doing here with deconstructing
the,
the features of both the original photo
and the,
um,
the painting.
And then we're swapping those features,
a overwriting of the photo features with
the painting features and that gives
this,
uh,
these kinds of outputs.
But the surprising thing here is that
there isn't much sort of what you would
regard as creativity here and yet you
get these kind of very interesting
outputs.
So it may be that creativity isn't as
mysterious as it seems to us when we
have ultimately find out what it is
now I'm just going to end by talking a
little bit about the bigger picture and
sort of the impact that ai might have in
the future.
And uh,
so,
you know,
I think some of the big problems are
facing us as a society or information
overload and system complexity.
So,
you know,
everywhere we go now it daily use by
inflammation.
So things like,
um,
obviously genomics,
big data in general,
but in the world of TV know
entertainment.
I mean there's so many TV channels now
and modes of watching things.
How can you really find what it is that
you're interested in?
And personalization is one kind of
technology that might help,
but it doesn't really work because it's
really based at the moment on quite
primitive sort of wisdom of the crowds,
collaborative filtering technology and
that doesn't give you unique
recommendations that are unique to your,
what I would call long tail of
interests.
And then in terms of system complexity,
the kinds of systems we would like to
master,
you know,
climate disease,
energy,
macroeconomics,
even particle physics are becoming so
complex now that even teams of the,
of the best and brightest human experts
are having difficulty comprehending the
implications are of these systems and
actually making useful predictions about
them.
So I think solving intelligence,
solving ai is potentially a kind of
metal solution to all these problems.
If we can solve intelligence,
then maybe we can use it to help us,
um,
as human experts,
uh,
get a better handle on all these other
systems.
And my dream really the thing I'd like
to use a January ai for is to build ai
scientists or to make ai assisted
science possible.
And of course,
if we have something this powerful,
then obviously we need to think about
the ethics of that,
of the use of it.
And as with all new powerful
technologies.
And I think ai is no different from many
other technologies in the past in this
regard.
We have to be a very cognizant about
using these technologies ethically and
responsibly.
And although human level Ai,
I think general ai is there many decades
away,
I think we should start the debate now
and when we,
that's what we're doing,
both is our own internal ethics
committees,
but also by supporting academic work and
academic conferences on these topics.
And then finally with a nod to
neuroscience,
I think building Ai,
uh,
actually in this way,
this neuroscience inspired way now help
us better understand the mysteries and
the workings of our own minds.
And I think in the future,
you know,
I think we're on part of the journey
we're on,
is that as we try to distill
intelligence into an algorithmic
construct,
if we then compare that with the
capabilities of the human mind,
I think we'll better understand about
what's unique and special about our own
minds,
like dreaming creativity and perhaps
even the great consciousness question.
Um,
and there's firemen said,
one of my all time scientific heroes,
what I cannot build,
I do not truly understand.
Thanks for listening.
Thank you.
That was brilliant.
If we get the lights up,
I'm going to ask one question but not
hog the limelight here.
And I'll hand over to the audience.
We're going to have 20 minutes.
So I'm having have a little pause.
Have a think about what you want to ask
Dennis because they're probably provoked
a so much kind of thinking.
One question I've got very simple one
actually is.
Well,
I was amazed by,
was that what you,
what your details,
your 20 year plan,
you know,
get your chest skills sorted,
in terms of those virtual environments
in gaming.
Then,
then you needed the nude,
but that was the first 20 years and you
just talked about decades away because I
think people are pretty obsessed with
taking that raw data in building the
picture of the environment where we're
at Atari Games.
But I knew that breakout trick,
but anyway,
we're Atari Games and then the other end
of the spectrum is the AI scientists
taking raw.
What's,
what.
So just give us a sense in the
generation you'll read what's a
realistic moon landing in your term?
Yeah.
I touched on some of those things.
Um,
in that neuroscience slide of the things
with big things I think are important to
solve that beyond like the Atari Games,
of course,
we're sort of on the first rung of the
ladder that the Atari thing was
significant because it was the first
time anyone built what we call an end to
end agent.
So something that took data and then
make decisions.
And did that in one big cycle.
Um,
obviously I think the next big
breakthroughs will be kainate really
learn abstract concepts,
um,
and go beyond just perceptual inputs and
have a wheel underlying understanding of
the semantics of the world it finds
itself in.
So that's,
I think,
um,
you know,
for us is our big kind of thing.
I mean,
is this going to be exponential like the
way computers developed that we're gonna
be in 20 years,
be bowled over by the,
the speed of progression?
I think it's hard to
because we've only got one of you and
you're not going to be here forever.
We want to know how much we can do.
I think it's hard to predict because,
um,
you know,
we need at least a dozen really huge
breakthroughs and uh,
I think to get all that way and,
and,
and research breakthroughs are
notoriously hard to putting the
timescales off.
So I think we'll,
we'll have,
you know,
several very surprising things over the
next few years.
Um,
but you know,
as to how far we'll get all the way.
I think it's,
it's too hard to say from here,
I'm being a personalized timescales for
that.
Brilliant.
I'm going to open it up because it's
easy for me.
I could be here all night,
but why don't we start there?
We'll get a mic to you.
That gentleman there with me,
then we'll come down to the front of how
many we've got going.
Hmm.
Tim Marshall.
If the squeamish,
we'll just close their eyes for a
second.
A few weeks ago I was at a conference,
uh,
where a robot was performing a prostate
operation a more than just performing
the operation there,
could actually understand the tumor and
make a decision whether to proceed or
not.
Today we've seen in the news the
challenges of providing healthcare.
Uh,
where do you think,
what role do you think ai can play in
diagnosis and treatment in health
because,
uh,
the way we practice medicine at the
moment is a 19th century paradigm.
So I'd be interested in your thoughts on
that.
Yeah,
it's great.
Actually,
a healthcare is actually one of the main
application areas we're focusing on.
First,
I think,
um,
we could probably revolutionize the sort
of quality of the care and efficiency of
it,
um,
you know,
as you say,
we're still using kind of 19th century
methods and uh,
I think,
uh,
having this sort of latest information
available in a digestible,
actionable way to surgeons and gps and
so on.
Um,
you know,
I think we'll must really help that
whole,
uh,
you know,
the whole healthcare space.
So it's something we're looking to get
heavily involved with in the next few
years.
Okay.
Why did you decide to publish the code
and were you ever worried or concerned
that when the ethics that might get into
the wrong hands?
Yeah,
I mean we try to be as open as possible
about what we're doing.
So we generally publish.
I'm almost everything that we do and
where we can,
we do open source things as well.
So actually our neural network libraries
called torch that we,
um,
build our algorithms on top of that.
That's open source and uh,
we felt and there was a demand for some
of the nature of reviewers and editors
that,
um,
you know,
it'd be nice if we could release our
code.
So we thought about it and we decided in
that case that was fine.
Um,
but,
uh,
you know,
that that may not always be the case for
the stuff we do a and we'll obviously
have to consider that on a case by case
basis,
but in general where we can,
we like to engage and support the
general academic community and we think
it's important that knowledge is shared
and I think that's the way that humanity
can advance as quickly as possible.
And the second road,
you're one of the largest brains on the
planet and I'm good now bought here and
um,
I'm gonna ask you that question,
which I'm sure you're expecting Stephen
Hawking
thing that the concern about ai that um,
once you let the genie out of the
bottle,
um,
we're all fucked.
What are you doing to try?
This is the regular.
Yes,
sure.
I mean,
I,
I've actually spoken,
um,
uh,
I had a long chat with Stephen Hawking
about this a few months ago and um,
I think he was,
well,
he was,
I think he lives very enjoyable and I
think he,
he,
we spent hours together.
We only spend half an hour,
but he was,
he had so many questions and I think he
was quite reassured after we talked
about how we will,
we specifically were approaching it.
Um,
and I think,
look,
you know,
there are big,
big issues here,
very big issues about um,
autonomous learning systems.
What goals should we give them?
What value system should we give them?
How can we make sure that,
that those are exactly what we want and
there are very tough pieces of research
that needs to be done.
Um,
there hasn't been much work done in that
area yet,
partly because there'd be no systems to
really try this out on.
So it's all been thought experiments and
I think if you,
do,
you know,
mostly the people thinking about this
and worrying about this to that extent
or not in the AI field right there.
Either philosophers or there other very
famous scientists or,
or industrialist but not actually
working on ai themselves.
And if they were working,
I think they would see that the problems
are much more prosaic at the moment.
And it's easy,
I think,
to get carried away with science fiction
scenarios that are,
you know,
many decades away.
My,
I have confidence that,
um,
as we get bill more powerful systems
will have much better ideas about the
answers to these questions that I just
talked about,
value systems and so on.
Uh,
and um,
you know,
mathematical proofs of empirical work
that will,
um,
allow us to have much better idea of how
to keep these systems on the control
when I'm pleased to see that you've got
the,
um,
the ethics committee that onboard and
you're thinking about these issues
issues,
but you have taken the Yankee dollar.
And I'm,
I am worried about this because you are
so smart and I hope that everything you
do actually improves the society route
kills us off.
Well,
so do I.
But uh,
but,
uh,
um,
you know,
I,
I think ai,
you know,
it could be the greatest thing for
humanity and the sense of if we build it
right,
we'll solve all these big issues that
corporate responsibility versus showing
through.
I think that's a big one,
isn't it,
in terms of where power lies in.
Sure.
I mean I should probably make a little
bit about that.
So obviously we spent a long time doing
due diligence ourselves on Google.
Right.
And we had a lot of other options
including stay independent and we
decided to join forces with them partly
because the people higher up at Google
agreed with things like the ethics
committee and thought it was a good idea
that governed the use of the technology
of deep mines technology.
We've already out ruled out things,
obvious things like military or
intelligence applications.
Um,
so,
you know,
the by default deep mind staff doesn't,
cannot be used for those things.
And then obviously we,
you know,
we've had our inaugural meeting of the
committee ethics committee.
There are very big illuminaries on that,
many of whom are some of the people that
you've mentioned who are worried about
this stuff,
not just the people who think positively
about it.
And a big part of that actually because
you know,
we are decades away,
is to just start educating everyone on
what the real issues are and separate
sort of fact from science fiction.
Um,
and I think that's the first time point
and then we can actually get to the hub
of the really core technical difficult
questions there are.
And there are some,
but I,
I'm very confident if we apply enough
brainpower onto it with enough time,
uh,
will solve those problems.
Right.
You,
you've been in Google now for about a
year.
Um,
can you,
can you give us a couple of examples or
anecdotes about how deep mind has
changed the company?
I'm taking over some processes changed
the way the company works your going
forward and just to tag onto the ethics
committee.
Why haven't you publicized or published?
Who's,
who's on it?
So,
um,
first question is I'm almost,
nothing's changed and that's the whole
point of it.
That was one of the main agreement.
So we,
we,
our,
our headquarters is still in the UK and
tinkering around King's cross.
We've built,
invested in the research team there,
so the whole of the minus still UK side
and uh,
you know,
we're very,
we work as a kind of semi autonomous
type of unit.
The plus size are the amount of compute
power that we have access to,
uh,
has really accelerated our progress and
obviously the other resources that.
Sorry,
I meant the other way around.
How is deepmind to,
to Google as a come?
Oh,
I see.
Um,
well,
so,
um,
that's harder to say.
I mean Google is very big,
but I think that we have actually a
effect to that in some senses a the way
that some other parts of Google research
do that work.
So there's actually thousands of people
in Google research and there's thousands
of people working on machine learning.
Um,
but we were sort of have a more coherent
a specific mission than the more applied
machine learning against done elsewhere
and google.
So I think we bring,
we bring together a kind of longer term
research focus that,
um,
I think maybe google wants more of now
and that requires quite different
organizational structures and management
processes,
which,
um,
you know,
some of,
uh,
some of which has been adopted over in
mountain view in Silicon Valley.
Now.
I'm,
so your second question was about the,
why don't we publicize stuff?
Well,
firstly I'm a,
you know,
we're very early days and uh,
there's a lot of scrutiny on this and
um,
there's nothing at the moment,
it's about simply about educating people
are ever getting everyone up to speed
with the issues.
Um,
once you start making things public,
then immediately that changes,
that can change the debate.
And I wanted to have a period of um,
sort of quiet behind the scenes,
a calm,
calm,
collected debate before we additionally
on ourselves this additional sort of
public scrutiny.
So at some point I think we will
announce who,
you know,
these people are,
and also a little bit about what the
issues are that are being discussed.
Having said that,
we already do lots of public things.
So that was a big conference in Puerto
Rico that was talking about ai ethics
and safety as another one at New York
University in January that we're
sponsoring and I'm keynoting and I'm on
a program committee of,
along with Facebook,
uh,
the heads of ais there and Microsoft and
some of the other companies.
So I think probably the next stage next
year will be to create a cross industry
panel,
um,
and bring together all the big companies
and academic labs that are working on
this in addition to our own internal
committee with your list.
Let's correct
for a few more.
We've got about 10 minutes.
So I think someone's got a mike here
though and then will go up to mother.
Thank you.
Yes,
that was a brilliant presentation.
Thank you very much for that.
I'm a was an engineer.
I'm now a slightly aged academic.
Um,
we work on the general a video gaming
machines,
so I appreciate that very much.
But when you go the next day up to
imagination,
then that must be so many individual
random coordinates,
if you like,
because I think we all imagined
differently,
um,
that you'll spend an infinite amount of
time trying to analyze these to actually
make machines if you're like,
imagine implant fashion.
So how do,
how do you cope with these coordinates?
You can't build it as well because a lot
of the audience and for the television
audience here,
I can see,
I suspect there was a bit of a shudder
around east kidding.
He's the creative,
which is,
yeah,
that's a bit clunky.
We should kind of merging the course
versus when the first director,
the first writer,
when those,
the invite the points in the
environment,
the choices become financial versus a
space invaders.
Exactly.
It's like the rice on the chess board.
Yeah.
So I think,
uh,
I think most people's jobs in here safe
for a long time ago is quite hard.
So I don't think it's going to be any
directors,
you know,
directing something,
the quality of Ridley Scott or
something,
you know,
that's probably going to be one of the,
if,
if ever one of the last things that that
competes will be able to do.
So we asked talking about very
constrained things where,
um,
you know,
that's a very difficult thing that
humans of course do better than,
than way better than computers is we,
you know,
they can have this rudimentary kind of
brute force imagination.
But one of the big things that humans do
is they have aesthetic judgment,
right?
They know that I'm not,
all Paul's are equal and some of them
are likely to be more fruitful than
others.
Even if you compare chess,
grandmaster playing the chess compared
to a computer,
they,
you know,
computer might look at millions of moves
to make that one decision.
Whereas a transplant not only look at a
few hundred but judicial ones,
and they in some sense our brains even
filter out a,
our low level power brain or any of the
kind of moves or trajectories that are
not going to yield anything useful.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
the,
when you do that filtrate,
are you working on.
Well,
we are talking that filtration part of
that is,
is to do with how well you
model of the world that you're in.
So if you're better at modeling the
world,
then what that means is you should make
better predictions about what are going
to be useful things to spend your
compute time,
uh,
imagining or thinking about a and at a
moment where,
you know,
we're still very early stages of that.
Sorry.
Hi,
David Abraham from Channel Four.
Um,
you touched on the challenge of,
um,
how many choices people have,
an entertainment and something that we
in our industry is spending a lot of
time thinking about.
Um,
are you,
um,
working more specifically on the area of
recommendation engines and are you going
to be,
as it were,
capturing the power of that algorithm
and behalf of Google?
Yeah,
we are looking at recommendation systems
and um,
you know,
uh,
in all forms actually all sorts of forms
and a,
I think it's a very interesting area and
it's something that our technology is
quite,
uh,
quite sort of applicable to.
Again,
it's about,
you know,
can you model a user journeys and
trajectories through things and in a way
that,
um,
you know,
then delivers much more compelling
content or recommendations and I think,
uh,
you know,
the current systems we have are not good
enough.
Um,
and you know,
we're,
we're experimenting in that.
Again,
we don't,
we're,
we're quite early days with that and
we're looking at that for things both
internally at Google and external
dcx external because I think that will
be deeply intriguing to a number of us
in the room who are working in the media
business about how to serve up stuff in
a world where choices.
Yeah.
Exploded.
And the general application of those few
years know,
think it'd be announcing stuff,
products coming out.
I think maybe it might be the wrong
word,
forgive my ignorance,
but systems by which the likes of
channel for the BBC,
other broadcasts in the room,
independent companies conserve their
content that we think that's not far
away.
Yeah.
I think in the next couple of years
you'll start seeing under the hood a
algorithms helping the,
these kinds of recommendation systems
and then maybe four or five years our
actual hope,
totally new systems that you might
interact with in a different way than we
do now.
Personally.
We got,
we're coming towards the last few,
but we'll get through as many as I can
from IBM.
I think it the other big investors in
Ai,
and I liked your comments around the big
breakthroughs is probably takes more
than one player to go to,
is to,
to the future space.
Um,
uh,
had a couple of questions in treatment
in your talk.
One was go.
So,
so years ago,
I think there was a big effort around
going who was the big one that was hard
for computers to solve.
It might be a bit esoteric for this
audience.
And then the second question,
just to bring this to the point,
is a,
for rts,
how can ai be used not to supplant
creativity but to enhance and support it
and allow us to do more creative things
as humans,
not as computers.
Let's do a quick one on the first one
because you might wanna do that
afterwards.
And it's really.
Yeah.
So go,
go for it.
As you don't know is it is an oriental
board game,
which is probably the most complex game
there is.
This is what they play in China and
Japan instead of a career instead of
chest.
And um,
one reason it's been so hard for
computers to crack is that the branching
factor,
the number of choices you have in each
booth is the order of 100,
whereas in chat is more like 20.
So as you start planning that branch,
in fact explode.
So if you're going to do it in a brute
force way,
there aren't enough.
I think atoms in the university describe
how many go positions there are.
For example,
bet you're good at.
Go on.
I'm reasonably good at go where you will
champion champion.
But,
but,
but um,
and then the second problem is that uh,
in chess,
because chess is a very materialistic
games,
so the queen is worth more than a real
console.
It's quite easy to hand program and
evaluation function to tell you whether
your program is winning or losing or how
well it's doing in that position.
Whereas in go,
all the pieces are worth the same.
They're just,
there's just one piece and so whether
you're winning or not as much more about
the overall pattern of the board.
So it's a much more beautiful game in
some sense,
very aesthetically pleasing,
but it's much harder to hand code and
evaluation function.
So,
um,
yeah,
we have,
we're going to have some very big
announcements to make ongoing.
I mean,
it's sort of been the holy grail for the
AI research community for the last 20
years since the blue actually be cast
off.
Um,
sorry.
Yeah,
sure.
So,
uh,
yeah,
and then so then,
then the,
the,
the last question was on a train that's
really the same thing I'm thinking about
in science to write and,
and with doctors and with one reading as
ai surfacing the right information for
you in a much more digestible way so you
can just leverage that for whatever it
is
we took the recommendation area.
Is there anything else in your head you
might just springs to mind in terms of
the creative process,
the creation of media?
I think that's a lot tougher.
So I think the recommendation is the
obvious one.
We are looking at things like music,
which is a,
a kind of more constrained domain for a
computer than visuals.
I mean,
which is incredibly hard,
right?
And uh,
this is a very interesting work being
done in music,
music composition,
a music analysis,
uh,
which I think is pretty promising.
So I would imagine that would be the
next place.
Very good.
I'm going to take three more because
we're really running out of time.
I'm sorry,
because we could just keep going.
We're not here to take you guys weren't
here.
Is there,
and got a microphone on them because
we'll just get the nice gentleman in the
back.
Want to have A.
Because I've been very front focus that
we don't want to be on the road right at
the back there.
IBM,
we've been sheep.
The from the search of pain,
pleasure during
our own cultural history and it's shaped
the way that we're thinking,
the way we are behaving.
How can you teach a pain and pleasure to
a machine?
Well,
one question is whether we,
whether we need to,
but it's also,
or whether we should and um,
uh,
but there is sort of,
this speaks to this idea actually that
we look at internally of intrinsic
motivation.
We call it.
So,
you know,
there are emotions and other things that
drive human behavior,
not just external rewards.
Um,
so,
uh,
you know,
and at the moment our machines don't
have anything like that.
But,
um,
maybe to do more complex tasks or you
know,
where the mobile working in game worlds,
where there is conveniently a score most
most of the time,
but even if you start going to more
complex games,
mope all open ended things like
minecraft.
Now there isn't a score anymore,
right?
So how are you going to decide what you
should do?
What is,
what's useful,
what's good that you're making progress?
And I'm talking about the agent system
here.
So,
um,
and of course that's more like the real
world for us as as humans and yet
somehow we have our own internal drives
probably that had been evolved to that
help influence our behavior.
So I think it's interesting to think
about.
Um,
and you know,
we have,
neuroscientists are experts in these
areas who work with us as consultants
and it's something I'm very fascinated
by.
Um,
but,
uh,
you know,
we don't have a definite answer on that
yet.
Thank you.
Two more.
So we'll take the gentleman at the back
of it.
You almost don't want to have a question
about,
I got hand up the.
Yes,
there is rather back there.
I just feel,
and then we'll take the gentleman in the
red as the last question.
No pressure.
My,
my question leads on quite well from the
last.
Actually I was thinking,
have you thought about generalizing the
goals?
So you talked about how the,
the uh,
observations and you have,
um,
actions that you take,
but presumably you define the goal.
Then you tell the system how to measure
its goals and if we're thinking about ai
as something which is a servant to,
to a human intelligence,
then have you thought about ai which can
derive its goals from the environment.
Can,
can also,
and also as humans,
we segment our goals.
We might have life goals,
but we focused on sub goals to get
there.
And also I'm not just know,
I'm sort of imagining a human saying to
a system,
can you help me with this and that and
the ai being able to derive its goal
from the things that it hears,
but also going further than that,
being able to derive goals before
they're specifically instructed.
So,
um,
being able to anticipate goals that
people might want that to ai.
So we realize it
go to high school.
That's fine.
I mean,
that's very,
you know,
that's a great question.
And actually it's a fascinating research
areas.
Can the machines learn their own goals?
A bite through observation of,
you know,
learn what it is you like through
observing you for example.
Right?
And then trying to,
you know,
maybe even be able to preemptively guess
what is that you need before you even
ask for it.
Um,
so I think,
uh,
you know,
those systems are very interesting.
I mean even there you will still have
some kind of top level goal which is to
satisfy the user,
right?
Although it may learn what the sub goals
are and that's another very active area
of research is how do you break down a
large go into,
into automatically into sub goals.
And of course that's something our minds
do effortlessly.
You know,
if you're going to plan to um,
you know,
a trip to Paris from hair,
um,
your brain is not going to plan over
your muscle fiber movements all the way
from here to Paris,
right?
It's the yet.
That's how robotics works.
And it might feel like they have no
defining of hierarchy,
well your act,
but it's actually going to do is like,
you know,
at high level you need to get to the
Eurostar terminal and then take a train
there and so on,
and then only at the point where you get
up off that chair,
does your brain then go and unpack the
muscle fiber movement of get,
you know,
get up off the chair and uh,
and walk.
So,
um,
whereas at the moment,
because we haven't solved this problem
of automatically generating subgoals I'm
a robot,
for example,
trying to do that task,
we'd have to plan over the primitive
action movements all the way to Paris.
And of course this is not feasible and
therefore not tractable.
Um,
because it ends up becoming,
you know,
speaks to the other gentleman's question
about you imagine all those paths from
here or muscle muscle fiber movements.
There's an infinite,
there's basically an infinite number of
them.
So,
um,
so we need,
that's one of the key things we need to
solve is the sub goal problem.
The last question.
Oh,
sorry.
Get that across.
Hmm.
Malcolm have a broadcast engineer
following off from an earlier one and
your list of memory,
navigation,
imagination,
etc.
You didn't have emotions and that's
where we're going to be dealing with an
interacting with humans.
How explosive is that with Your
conflicts of ethics and parameters?
Yeah,
I mean,
again,
this,
um,
relates to the question identifying down
here about emotions.
We currently.
I'm,
uh,
you know,
there is no equivalent of that in our
systems.
Um,
but,
uh,
if you think of inch in emotions,
and probably this is too simplistic,
but part of emotions are internal drives
a give us internal drives,
then that's something we do need to
explore,
um,
and try and work out what ones might be
needed and it might be we need similar
ones so that these systems can empathize
with humans.
Um,
you know,
obviously there's a great channel for
series.
I think that people,
some people in the audience with humans,
which I really love and that's
interesting.
You know,
they're trying to empathize with the
humans that they serve.
Alternatively,
you might want to have systems that have
no a very different types of drives that
help them be complimentary to what
humans are good at,
so I could imagine we might need both
types of daily,
so motion.
Just want to fish on the using essential
that you're going to have to cope with
emotion as a driver of if you'd like
some types of emotions,
relations,
so there's two reasons you might want
the one so that we can see these systems
can empathize and work better.
Hand in hand with humans.
Yeah.
The other thing is if they.
It turns out the environments they're
in,
there aren't many external reward
signals.
They have to have some internal drive to
get them going in the right direction.
It was a privilege.
I'm going to hand to nomi climate from
the president,
the iet in a second,
but dennis has been one year.
Thank you.
Thank you
dennis.
As the president of the iet,
we're absolutely delighted to have co
hosted this lecture with the royal
television society and delighted to have
someone of your extraordinary caliber
miss events like today for fill,
part of the iet charitable remit,
which is to inspire,
inform,
and influence people and I don't know
about you,
but you sure as hell have inspired,
informed and influenced me on a topic
that I believe is going to change the
world.
I love the idea that your ai journey
started with games and the machine
learning is done through play.
Pretty mucH the same as it is for
humans.
I've enjoyed the way that you've made it
all sound pretty straightforward
actually from our hippocampus to
imagining rats to the quest for machine
creativity and it just sounded quite
logical that your journey to the to the
point to have your mission,
which is use ai to solve everything else
seems quite reasonable.
Your quest for the ai scientist to
really tackle some of those big
important challenges.
So listening to you,
it all sounds incredibly real and
feasible.
That ai can make a positive difference
to humanity and even if it's not going
to be directing any movies anytime soon.
So once again,
please join me in thanking dennis
hassabis,
founder of deep mind for an absolutely
fantastic.
Sure.
Thanks and I will do.
I'd like to thank our feisty chair.
You did an excellent job.
Tyndale be the ceo of bbc worldwide.
I think we've all been inspired,
informed,
and influenced,
so it's been very nice for me to be part
of this.
Thank you very much for coming here.
We did like to to hear that drinks are
now served outside.
Thank you.
thank you.